one of the leading causes of death in
the United States is often underreported
and very misunderstood it's called
chronic obstructive pulmonary disease or
COPD it's the nation's third biggest
killer after heart disease in cancer
about 150,000 Americans die of COPD
every year among women it is even more
deadly than breast and ovarian cancers
combined well Ted Koppel focuses on the
disease for a report next week on CBS
Sunday morning his wife Grace Ann was
given only a few years to live when she
was diagnosed 16 years ago today the
couple advocates for more research into
prevention and treatment Ted and Grayson
Dorney Koppel join us at the table 16
years ago when you were still here grace
and Dorney couple so that's good the
doctor was wrong about that yes I am
healing am i used by day yes we are glad
about that and I know Ted's really happy
about that but this is what this is what
fascinates me about this disease I was
asking around this morning most people
have never heard of COPD and to hear
that it it causes such death in such
great numbers why is it such a mystery
that we don't know about it I believe
it's because of the failure to have a
cure oh don't realise that it is highly
treatable family doctors often don't ask
about the symptoms and signs and
patients themselves don't know to say
look what happened to you
yeah first tell us how did you know you
even had a problem I couldn't breathe
mm-hmm
I literally could not walk across a
space like this room without stopping to
catch my breath
I couldn't sleep without pillows back
propped up behind my back I couldn't
walk up a few steps what did you think
it was I thought I had a rare disease it
was a great shock to me to find out that
my disease was so common and it's not
curable it's not reversible
we have no medications to stop the
progress of the disease Grayson were you
diagnosed right away you go to the
doctor
you have COPD no what do you know I was
I was told that if I lost 10 pounds I
feel like a new woman Wow but it was
after six weeks after that when I
literally was stopped in my tracks I
couldn't do anything Ted when you heard
this diagnosis all I can tell you Nora
is that night I mean grace Ann asked how
long how much time do I have and she was
told three to five years you need to
start making end-of-life preparations we
just went back to the hotel that night
held each other all night long and
sobbed you know I mean it was
devastating and that's what so first of
all doctors don't diagnose it as quickly
as they should then they tell people
you've got an incurable disease you've
only got a couple of years left to live
I mean if people aren't depressed before
they go to the doctor's office they walk
out of there wondering you know how are
we gonna survive so describe the
treatment because you've beaten the odds
the treatment has inhaled medications
similar to the medications used for
asthma and they they have to be taken on
a daily basis and exactly as prescribed
the other treatment we have that only 3%
of Americans have an opportunity to
participate in it's pulmonary
rehabilitation which is a comprehensive
program of knowledge about the disease
exercise learning about nutrition
learning when you're going to have an
exacerbation which is a lung attack
basically and that is not available I
was just gonna say let me emphasize
again three percent of the people who
have COPD and thirty million people in
this country 16 million had been
diagnosed the estimate is there another
10 to 15 million who have not yet been
diagnosed we've got to diagnose them
we've got to increase the availability
of pulmonary rehabilitation and here's
another little kicker it is the number
three killer in the country
you know where it stands in terms of
funding at NIH 150 v right we need fund
and it affects more women than men does
age have anything to do with that
well you're not diagnosed until you're
in your 40s it's a disease of middle age
there is a small proportion of people
who have genetically most people are X
mockers but 8 and 10 smokers don't get
COPD and 25% of us have never smoked a
cigarette Wow is that why it's
underreported I think that's one reason
you know a great hand refers to it as
the Rodney Dangerfield of diseases it
don't get no respect
yeah and the fact of the matter is
because so many smokers do get it
there's a tendency of people to say hey
you know you got no one to blame but
yourself I'm looking forward to your
report a lot of us are next Sunday on
Sunday morning but because you're
interviewing grace I wonder what it's
like to interview someone who you love
so much number one and number two when
you know the answers practically to all
the questions what's that like
interviewing so it's not easy practice
well we're glad Greyson you beat the
odds
good call Weight Watchers has two cups
and you have she's better hydrated than
I has constant coughing shortness of
breath is an ex-smoker Moore who worked
in an occupation with a lot of dust and
vapors and gas mention it to your doctor
and get tested very good advice thank
you